as a person who had
has been speaking in public for quite a
while i'm
aware of the fact that people don't
necessarily read
abstracts or titles
or or don't read them closely
particularly if there's only one track
it's like well you're going to be in
this room anyway
so this talk is called evident code at
scale
and i want to talk about code and scale
quickly and then move on to the word
evident
i'm not talking about web scale here or
data scale data scale is kind of
orthogonal to
the interest that i have here i can make
a one line program that can do a
trillion things
right they can they can process a lot of
data so i'm not talking about that kind
of scale
i'm talking about uh what it's like when
projects
scale when they change course
right so when a project is going in one
direction and it changes course and
picks up new things
over time and i think this is
particularly important at this point
in closure's life cycle because we're
getting uh we're past the initial wave
of adoption and we're getting people who
are coming
behind that wave and they're asking
questions like wow this looks really
great but
what's it going to be like when my code
base is
doing 10 times as much stuff
accomplishing 10 times as much value
how's it going to be to manage that
and notice that i was careful not to say
that the code base was 10 times bigger
i only said that the code base was
accomplishing 10 times
uh as much stuff because that's really
what we care about right we're afraid we
think that the size of a project is a
proxy for
for problems right the length of the
code is
scary but it's really about getting
things done
and we're going to talk about what it
means for code to be evident
i'm going to follow dick gabriel's lead
from yesterday and you don't have to
read any part of the slide except the
colored
part you can ignore the the dark text so
evidence is perceptible clear
obvious apparent and i'm going to be
giving examples
from the two projects that i've had the
chance to work on over the last three
years
which is closure itself and atomic
i want to start with declarative
programming
because uh the word declarative and
problems with the word declarative
really led to rich's desire to reach
back into the dictionary and
try to stuff something into a word a new
word or an old word again
uh into the word evident and declarative
programming as we all know
is incredibly awesome uh and in
particular
it is about saying what the program
should accomplish
rather than how the program is going to
go about accomplishing it
and we're going to look at this through
a small example first
which is rock paper scissors lizard
spock
uh those of you who are in the training
class this is taken straight from the
code example from the training class and
so
here's a nice declarative statement
about the
rock paper scissors lizard spock domain
and like any good agile developer i
actually simplified the problem
down to just rock paper scissors i'll
get that one right and then i'll figure
out
you know we'll go enterprise and we'll
add lizard and spock later
so this is great right this anybody can
read this right paper dominates rock i
hope i got these right i was typing this
kind of late at night
rock dominates scissors scissors
dominates paper
that's nice and declarative it's not
enough to make the program go
so you end up doing something and here
we have a
winner function that is a referentially
transparent pure function
that uses that dominates map to say
given two plays and rock paper scissors
which one is the winner now one of the
things that's interesting about this
is it already sort of gets to the idea
that you can be declarative at one level
and not in another
right you could have something that's
beautiful and declarative and underneath
it that thing could be
functional right not a logic program but
a functional program or even an
imperative program
uh would this winner function be better
or worse if i went to
traditional uh mutable java approaches
and made
a state stateful object that represented
that guy and had him change states
that be better or worse worse
for some value what if i made a logic
program out of that
if i take i took that and did it in core
logic what would the core logic version
of this be able to do that this version
can't
it would be it would be web scale no
what would the logic program be able to
do that the functional program couldn't
right the the logic program could could
run in a bunch of different directions
right so even though this is purely
functional there's still an order to it
right there are inputs and then you get
to an output if i was the logic
programmer you could run it forward or
you could run it backwards i could say
here's an outcome and a play what was
the other play
right or here's an outcome generate all
the plays right so you can run it in a
bunch of different directions
which is why logic programming is the
bomb and we should all be abandoning
functional programming and
heading straight as fast as possible to
logic programming
so everything should be declarative
everybody should just reach out and give
your interstate monad a hug
and just forget about ever doing
anything
that's stateful you know those reference
types and closure stuff like that you
don't need that
well there are clearly reasons not to be
declarative
the obvious one and i think closure does
this great is you can have a functional
not in the functional programs but a
functional requirement to have identity
right if we said that the rock paper
scissors is an online game and i can
watch you as you play and see what
you're doing we've now created a
requirement for identity
in the system likewise you could have
non-functional requirements
that might push you off of using
a logic programming approach maybe the
logic programming approach
the search that's used by the logic
engine doesn't prune your particular
problem very well
and so the performance isn't there so
you'd like to be using logic but you
can't
you could also have a constraint i
suspect that the most likely constraint
that you might have would be uh my team
doesn't know how to write logic programs
yet
so so that but that's that's a
legitimate constraint right
we better not build everything out of
logic programs because we don't have
that
uh we don't have that skill set mastered
as an industry
uh the point here is that declarative
is not a
is not a perfect word for goodness right
we can't slide from
from declarative to that's you know
that's the right answer which is
uh phase one of motivating uh the use of
the word evident instead
so what would it mean to write programs
that were evident
a key idea i think in evident code is
making good use of abstractions
and i have some fairly concrete advice
here i should say now this talk is going
to have a lot of code
it's not going to be one of those fluffy
rich hickey idea talks
there's going to be a ton of code and
there's going to be really specific
advice
so in closure we have protocols as our
primary way of talking about abstraction
we have other ways as well
and it turns out that there is an ideal
number
of methods in an abstraction that you
should be aiming for
which is zero we abstract too much we
make up abstractions where abstractions
do not exist
uh when we have abstractions they are
often fantastically big and conflated
i'm going to show two examples of
ugliness that comes from this that both
come from awesome libraries
so i don't want this to be taken as uh
as criticism of the libraries in
question
the first one is from java itself so
this is the map interface in java and
it's
way too big what's rolled together in
here
if you're not sure go and look at all
the closure interfaces
that maps implement that break this out
into the different pieces
uh that ought to be factored into and
you have to ask yourself
why does why do java interfaces end up
looking like this
one piece of the problem is that people
don't think carefully through and carve
out really small abstractions
but i suspect that a real cause of the
problem
is that people don't want to have to
write casts
right so they have these three things
that they commonly use together
and just because of the way the language
works because they would have to write
casts back and forth all the time they
end up making things like this
so they can treat this thing as a
cohesive whole
the other problem is that in all too
many programming environments
we end up using the same mechanism for
abstraction
and for concretion right so we have
methods and classes
to represent abstractions but then we
use methods and classes
to represent things as well this is one
of the request
objects from the aws api
which is a terrific really
capable api and it's really well thought
out and yet it has these awful
uh ugly concretions in it
and the funny thing about it is how many
people have used aws api from java
say about 10 15 if you use this for a
while
you start to get a sneaky suspicion that
the aws api was actually written by a
program
right they actually have i suspect
a data description of all of this that
actually they run through some
transformer which they have not
published
which emits the java program so
they don't actually live in this world
they're not forced to
to work with these concretions in this
kind of shape
so we have a lot of problems uh getting
abstraction right just from the get-go
and we have a lot of
bad examples or or misleading examples
even in really good libraries
and probably the biggest thing
especially when you're introducing
people to closure
that you're going to run into and i get
this again and again and again
is wow this all seems really great but
where's encapsulation
right yeah this immutable data is really
cool but where's encapsulation
and there actually is a way to talk
about that that's useful this is a
this is not computer science this is
just dictionary definition of
abstraction
the job of abstractions is to reduce the
information content of something
so that you can deal with it and not
have to deal with the whole of the thing
just deal with the part that you care
about
and if you take this notion of
abstraction
and you combine it with rich's picture
of the epical time model
enclosure so this is if you haven't seen
this picture before
that box moving across the middle is
some sort of closure reference type over
time
and pure functions advanced reference
types from one state to another
and then down at the bottom there are
observers
and if you take the notion of
abstraction as reducing information
it becomes clear why if you don't make
this separation
people get really confused about what
encapsulation
should do if i have an abstraction
around action around function then
that's saying
i have to provide less information to
make this action go
that's a good deal right you know i i
have to know six things to trigger this
thing in the system
no i want to know only one thing i don't
want to know a bunch of details in order
to trigger
something in my system on the other hand
abstraction on the perception side
is just reducing the amount of
information i can get
right we make something smaller on the i
have to do work side that's great that's
less work i have to do
we make something smaller on the
observed side
not so good
this is not licensed to observe all
kinds of things you don't need to
observe and make
yourself unnecessarily dependent on them
but it is i think an argument
against an object-oriented programmer's
need
to go through and encapsulate everything
because all they're doing is hiding
information from themselves after you
break the world into action and
perception
so daytonic has about 50 protocols or
interfaces
and they are divided between action
things that are on the top of that slide
and
perception on the action side there are
protocols that describe
the relationships between the services
so if you look at the three different
things that
rich called out the storage layer and
the transactor and the peers
right there are protocols or
abstractions between them
there are also smaller protocols and
abstractions inside
the various moving parts uh typical
design to make those kinds of
abstractions and then there are also
abstractions around perception it's
unusual
in most closure programs to create new
abstractions for perception what
abstractions do we use for that
maps vectors seeks and so on
but because datomic is a database it has
actually a few
uh a few new generic data structure
types that don't actually
map to any of the perception
interfaces that are already in closure
so one example of that
is entity so this is a
perception related abstraction right
this is some way to let me find out
information
and uh this lets me walk up to something
that i got out of the database and say
what attributes can i see about you
and
here's an action example so this is that
portion of
the datomic api that updates the
database
that's all of it that's the entire
update
abstraction in the entire system right
just those two
methods so the total size
of update is two now remember i told you
what's the ideal size
zero so i'm i apologize that the atomic
has such a bloated api that there are
actually two methods that you need to
have to make updates
we'd like to try to do better as we go
through the talk maybe we'll find a way
to
do a little better than and so the
things i would say about
abstraction when you want to make code
evident is that abstractions need to be
fine-grained
so a small number of methods preferably
zero
abstractions need to separate perception
and action which comes fairly naturally
in closure because you don't write
perception related abstractions right
you don't sit down and write beans
with getters right you just use maps and
when you make a def record you don't get
a new perception related abstraction you
continue to use the abstractions that
are already provided for you
so perception is generic
this is probably fairly easy to do
naturally in closure right you if you're
just following what others are doing
you're going to get this
right to a pretty good degree although
the fine-grained abstraction part is
always hard
i don't think that abstraction is
necessarily the most important part of
evident though
i think that actually data values
programming with data
does more to make a code base evident
than abstraction can and i'm going to
show several examples of this
the first one is queries so
uh data log queries in daytonic are data
and we're going to go through this
quickly uh this overlaps those who have
watched the little 10-minute video
this overlaps with that sum but i'm
going to call out some different points
as we go so a data pattern describes
something you want to look up
so it's going to constrain results and
bind some variables and in this data
pattern
the data patterns follow entity
attribute value transaction
in this case we've left out transaction
because we don't care about it
and you can put a constant in a data
pattern if you do that it acts as a
constraint
i'm only asking questions about the
email attribute
you can put a variable in and that says
fill in the blanks with these
give me back customers give me back
emails
the choice of where you put constants or
variables is up to you
so here i've put a constant in entity
position so now i'm saying
find entity 42's email and also put the
variables anywhere so here i'm saying
tell me all the attributes that entity
42 has
and i'm not saying the values of those
attributes i'm saying the attributes
themselves
right 42 has a first name if i actually
want to find out what 42's first name
is then i could put a variable in the
value position as well
you take these data patterns and
put them into a find clause to specify
what pieces you want to get back
so the find clause is going to have one
or more variables
to say this is the piece that i want to
get back and then you can start to build
up
uh bigger things out of it so here we
have
i would like to find everybody in the
system
who has an email and has placed an order
and we're using email as our way of
identifying customers
so find all the customers who have
placed orders
and this is the point where i want to
draw the distinction carefully between
being declarative
and being evident and
um this is declarative
and evident but a declarative approach
to this doesn't have to be evident
and you can tell that i was writing
slides late there
we'll scratch that we'll wipe that out
in the video
so uh i could have a declarative
logic based query language that declared
what intermediate tables that i had to
go through to do that join would still
be declarative
right it'll be go get email and go get
customers but it would have to navigate
structure
as well and people would tend to say
that that's still declarative right that
would be in sql or that would be in a
logic programming language
that still is within the purview of
being declarative i could have a
declarative xml language
that explained how to convert everything
that's coming out of the database into
objects
that's still declarative but it's not
making my code more evident
right to create that second source of
truth or possibly confusion and maybe
the most interesting or subtle one
is i could have an explicit connection
or an explicit value in my query
language
or i could have an ambient value in my
query language
when you talk to a sql database the
notion of what the database is doesn't
show up in your query
right you're just talking to the
database and that makes sense because
you're going there
right you're going to this place that is
the database so you don't need to say
what that is what limitation does that
put on you
you have to go there what else does it
put on you how many databases can you
query against
one it's ambien right you don't have a
chance to say oh i want to query against
two days so this is three examples of
you could take this
purely declarative thing and muck it up
and have it be a lot less evident
right we could have structural
navigation through a document
or through a join table or we could be
converting it to objects all
declaratively
and hurting the evident nature of the
code
so the query api looks like this so now
we're plugging that query
in so q is the query function and this
query takes a
our query and then in this case a single
input some value of the database
now let's move to having more than one
input so you can add an n clause to a
query
that says i'm going to have more than
one input if that inputs a database it's
dollar sign prefixed
if it's a variable it's question mark
prefix and that lets you do things like
a parameterized query
so here we have a first input which is
the database
and a second input which is the email
that we want to look up
of course you notice that now that we
have more than one input we have to
actually specify the input
in the where clause and so that gets to
be verbose
right i'm not going to type the word
database all the time so it's idiomatic
just to use the dollar sign
and in fact it's idiomatic just to leave
it out
right because even though we don't want
to be limited to querying one database
a lot of times how many databases are we
querying one
right so we want to have that be as easy
as possible
so you can extend these queries with
predicates
so you can oh i should also mention by
the way that all of this stuff
is in this really novel new programming
language called the
atomic query language it may look
extremely familiar to people in this
room
so i'm not going to bother to explain
the syntax and where the parentheses go
and
you know all that kind of stuff so this
predicate says the price is uh
greater than 50 and you can add
predicates into your queries like that
you can also add functions into your
queries so here we have
a shipping function that says given a
zip code and a wait for a package
tell me how much it's gonna cost so
functions take arguments they have to be
bound
for the function to be invoked and then
they bind variables
uh with returns and so here we have a
substantially more interesting query
this says find me all the customer
product conversa
combinations where the shipping cost
dominates the product cost
right we're worried that our customers
are unhappy
because they try to buy something and
the shipping cost is actually more than
the cost of the thing
and so in order to figure that out you
actually have to implicitly join across
the customer and where they are and the
price of what they're ordering and then
you have to call out
to this shipping estimate function and
that shipping estimate function can be
just any old function
in fact it could be a web service call
inside your query
i'm going to show you one more query
and i'm not going to explain it in
detail i'm going to go quickly
so this query says find all the people
in our system who have
recorded interests so we have something
in the system that lets people say i'm
interested in football or whatever
as entities and make datums
so this is a query of the database that
manufactures
datums what is this what is this query
it's an etl job all in a query
right it's a pure function it's a logic
program that takes data from one data
source
and produces the input that you pour
into another database to put
datums in that database so hereafter
i know you guys like to call it
threadlast but this guy is now called
the etl macro
schema is data so here is a description
of a single attribute this is from a
parts catalog
so the attribute is called part name
it's of type string a part can have only
one name so it's cardinality one
it's full text true because parts have
these long interesting names and we want
to find the
you know purple screwdrivers or whatever
and this actually came up on the atomic
mailing list this week somebody said you
know that's
that's a mouthful why don't we do this
instead
so we're going to have this thing called
create eav
and it's going to do all the work that
that other guy did but i'm not going to
have to type as much
but what's different between these two
things
quite a lot right with that map
describing the schema
i have this incredibly large api for
manipulating schema definitions what is
it
the map api it's not just closure right
you could do it from java right you
could call that all the map api
functions in java
i can make those schemas from any
language and this is really important
i can read schema without evaluating it
if we go to a function at the bottom
that makes schema
then you have to call that function
which by the way what does that do to
the api for everybody who's not coming
from closure
right you can see how this cascades
right if i'm going to if i'm going to do
this
then we got to expose create aiv in some
way that people can call it from scala
and groovy and
j ruby and whatever
the name versus positional argument also
has to do with the data being able to be
self-describing
and of course with maps i can extend it
easily if i wanted to say an additional
fact
and remember that atomic is an open
system right you can make you can
add any kind of datum to any kind of
entity if i wanted to add some new fact
to the schema
like this guy let's add units of measure
right so whenever we have a numeric type
we're just going to have a convention
that we also record what the unit of
measure is
for that numeric type what do i have to
do if my scheme is made out of maps
we have an api for that right a soch or
i can
or i can just type the map literal and
of course i can build these things from
programs
so we've seen that query is data and now
we've seen that schema is data
here's a more subtle one navigation is
data
so let's go back and uh think about that
entity interface again
so i'm holding on to an entity and i can
say let's say it's a person
i can say tell me all the attributes
that we know about you
and if one of those attributes is an
entity i can jump right down there
and say okay now tell me all the
attributes about you so
i'm really close to being able to
navigate the entire database
just by calling those two methods from
entity what's the fly in the ointment
well all those relationships are
directional right so i've said that a
person has an address
what if i want to go the other way well
the api solution is pretty
straightforward
and we have to come up with a better
name than reverse get but we're going to
add a method to the entity
api that says well if i'm going if i'm
navigating from an entity to a value
i call this and if i'm navigating to
what entity has me as a value
right if i'm going the other way then
we'll call reverse get
this is a disaster
because it takes away the data nature of
navigation
when the navigation is just data i can
navigate all the way around the database
by saying things like this tell me what
town
jack lives in now
what if i want to know who else lives in
jackson town
the underscore which is still data
says navigate that relationship in the
reverse direction so this says
go from jack to his town and then give
me all the people
in jack's town and navigation is data
which means that this is the slide i'm
happiest about so i want you to burst
into wild applause
the number of methods in atomic's graph
navigation api
is zero that's when right there
now i'm going to talk about some other
stuff enough about evident code
evident code is not really enough to
understand
a substantial application and so there's
a ton of other stuff
that we used while building atomic one
thing that we used
that was really refreshing is
specifications right so some major
components of the system actually have
pros specifications before they have
anything else
and obviously that's a you know careful
upfront design kind of thing so i know
it's
out of fashion but still kind of useful
it turns out
we have doc strings we make heavy use of
uh
pictures we draw lots of pictures i
would suspect we have
several hundred grapple uh things right
now and we do a ton of outlines
right the primary thing when i sit down
formerly i would have written give and
win then that's you know sit down and
start typing
now i just start writing those little
asterisks and making uh
outlines and posing questions and saying
you know here are the constraints that
we have to trade off and try to get
everything
sort of laid out and then
we probably should test this given that
it's a database
maybe a little so
i heard it said that tests were
executable documentation
which is really good news because my
abstract didn't say anything about
testing
and i want to talk about testing some
but because of this it's now part of
being evident to have a test suite so i
get to actually now
make a right angle turn in this talk and
talk about testing for about 10 minutes
so what is a test
there's a bunch of different pieces that
go into a test you have inputs right
there's got to be something
going in some sort of driver that does
the actual execution
output capture and then you probably
have validation
i've separated out validation because uh
if i had a test
that just ran the program and didn't
actually look at the outputs
it's still doing some minimal validation
what's it doing
make sure it didn't crash and make sure
it doesn't hang right so there's a
little bit of validation in there
a test could also usefully communicate
things about the system certainly we
want that
i mean i don't know how much we want
that i don't know how we will trade it
off with other things but we would like
our tests
to communicate about how our systems
work but
you wouldn't say i didn't have a test
suite because it was hard to read and
didn't communicate
right you wouldn't you wouldn't
invalidate its status as a test suite
you would just say it's an irritating
test suite
it still would they would still be tests
likewise i would like my test suite to
have record of what has happened in the
past
so for regression for example i'd like
to know what happened when i ran the
test week before
so when i run a test suite again i can
get
you know some assurance that things
haven't changed for example
so this is a an example from closures
test suite
and it's typical unit testing style and
it complex all of the different
key elements of testing inside of
individual functions so we're actually
testing that closure can add numbers
here and so the driver is the r
macro in um closure.test and the inputs
are hand curated right somebody sat down
and thought up those inputs
i'm pretty sure that's comprehensive
that that covers all the numbers that
you might want to add in closure
and then there are these outputs and
those are hand curated as well
so rather than do that
uh one thing that we like to do and in
fact it's great that atomic is out now
uh i wrote test generative to as part of
testing daytonic
so when i shipped that last year it was
something that had been built
internally to help us with testing and
i'm going to show one quick example of
generative testing
and i'm going to use the same example
that aaron and i use in the book
which is this game which is called code
breaker
or under the trademarked name mastermind
now that i've said the trademark name
you should all go and buy the real
mastermind from the real mastermind
people
and tell them that i sent you so that
they'll be happy at this
reference to their trademark stuff and
so the idea how many people have played
mastermind the real trademarked one
okay so the idea in this game is that
you're guessing these colored pegs
and you get two bits of information
after each guess how many colors are in
the right spot
which is the red pegs on this particular
little game and how many colors
are right but not in the right spot how
many pegs are or a matching color
and so to test something like this
generatively you want to have a function
that generates inputs so this is for a
four
a four slot version of uh mastermind
so this is a random secret
then you have the function you want to
test so this is the scoring function and
we don't have to worry about the details
of it
i'll just observe that the scoring
function returns a map of the two things
that you need to draw the ui
the number of exact matches in the
number of unordered matches
and then you have some validation
functions about invariance
so it turns out that scoring in
mastermind is symmetric
if you took my guess and said that was
the secret and flipped it around
right is it symmetric it's actually
useful to think through these things
when you're
not right it is symmetric also it's
certainly the case that scoring is
bounded by the number of pegs
right if there's only if i'm only
playing a four peg game and a score
comes back that adds up to five pegs
uh we know something is wrong and
the first thing that's important about
this is that you separated input
generation
and the function you want to test and
the validation the second thing is that
when you approach validation in this way
you end up not being in the same mindset
you were when you wrote the code
and actually preferably would be just
somebody else writing it given the spec
right this whole notion
of you write the test and you write the
code is a perfect recipe
for making the same mistake twice in a
row in a short time period
and then having something that makes it
look like everything's okay
right it's not a good deal i'm not
saying quit doing it it's better than
not doing anything
but it's not as assuring as as one might
like it to be
and then in test generative these things
are all connected together uh by a
driver
macro called defspec and so inside of a
deaf spec you have a thing that looks
like an argument list
which actually describes how to generate
arguments and then you have the function
under test and the validations that you
want to apply
so aaron gave a talk about this i guess
some people saw it i saw a couple of
tweets
i think this is this style is useful i
do not make any pretension that
test.generative
is thorough or complete or
even up to snuff of to similar libraries
and other functional languages where
people have been doing this for a long
time
so if people want to jump on it and
contribute a bunch of improvements that
would be most welcome
the other thing that i would point out
though is that in the mastermind case
you could actually just do all of them
right in in closure adding numbers i
didn't really have the option of saying
we're going to just do every possible
scenario
but in 4 slot mastermind you could
actually print out a table that has
every possible scenario
and this is pretty cool because you
print out this table and then you hand
it to somebody
and say jump around at random and spot
check 50 of them
and tell me if they're right and then we
will save a record of that test and
start running it as regression
without having to hand write any
validation code
and you might not choose to do that you
might say you know what i want to be
more careful than that i want to read
through all of it
or i want to hand write some validation
code but the fact that we have separated
input execution and validation lets you
make independent choices
lets you say i want to do this part and
not that part
test inputs and outputs are made of data
and so there's a lot you can do with
test inputs and outputs
and this is not going to be up to snuff
with the fancy visualizations that we've
seen in some of the other talks so
i'm a textual guy i'll just put that out
there before i show you these
lovely ascii art graphics
so here's an example of a test suite for
a
the brian's brain simulation
so here we have little pictures
uh in ascii art of different states of
the game and then a keyword that says
what state are we supposed to go to next
and so once you have learned the rules
of the game it's a lot faster to look at
these little pictures and say does that
is that right
than to have some nine entry data
structure
that says you know what is the current
relevant state of uh
of other spots on the board next to me
so this is one example of
making taking test data and making it
more visual another example
is to have your tests write
documentation so
this is a table of the different binding
forms
that are actually alighted this table
would be a lot longer and have more
columns but i chopped it down so it
would fit and be semi-readable
on the slide but this is a table of the
different binding forms
that are possible in atomic's query and
how they work the really cool thing
though
is if you lived in a world where you
were careful to think about time
as a reified thing then stateful
interactions are themselves data
because once you add the time element
right you just have
right this is the point about datums
having that transaction where you can
get back to time
and so you can start to have tests that
are
a table that shows a series of events
over time so this is a
example usage pattern of uh queuing
abstraction
showing that as i put things into the
queue and offer things from the queue
and pull the cue
what happens and so each line represents
a point in time
of the test of course
where it gets really exciting is when
you start to test interleavings
so this is a test
of how datomics
will automatically reconnect when the
transactor
dies and fails over so your transactor
dies
and you're a cheapskate so you weren't
running another one
so five minutes later amazon gives you
another one and then the piers reconnect
or your transactor dies and you're on a
big budget and you already had another
guy
sitting there waiting so in a few
seconds you roll over that guy
but the pier has to go through this
thing that includes retries and backups
and attempts to clean up the java
resources of the
connection and all that kind of stuff
and so this little
output here and this is again heavily
alighted
is from a simulation run where i'm
simulating
a series of 50 straight transactor
failovers
that's right so i'm making it seem as if
the transactor dies
and then these letters are just letter
codes that i made up
uh of different events that happen and
then you can look at this i the human
expert who was working on this can look
at these letters and say
is that interleaving possible right
could we do the cleanup action and then
fall asleep and then
is that possible or not now obviously in
a perfect world what would i do with
these inner leavings
if i wanted a really good test here i'd
write a logic program of some kind that
looked at them and actually could just
tell me
are these interleavings possible
i don't have to do that at first though
again because i have separated out
running the test capturing the results
reviewing the results by viewing them
and validation i can choose how far i
want to go down the road
so if this is a particular pain point in
the system and i want to go further down
the road then i can write a program
that evaluates this now i'm not going to
have a program that reads those letters
right behind those letters that's a
convenient print form for me to read
what's behind those letters
from a data structure perspective this
is closure what's back there
just lists and vectors and maps right so
if i was actually going to
programmatically
assert correctness on these order of
things and i would be actually
processing plain old data structures
i also want to be able to simulate
failure so here's a test that says
what happens when um
dynamodb doesn't work and in my test
i'm assuming that dynamodb has a little
more than one nine of reliability
not very much hopefully dynamo's gonna
have several more nines
than that but notice that my failure my
storage fail right there is
one in 20 right one time in 20 that i
try to use storage
uh it's going to fail now
there is not a one-to-one correspondence
between
storage failures and
writing a block so this is simulating a
failure writing the log
what are the data structures in the
atomic when they're put on disk
what is always the answer for what is a
data structure enclosure underlying data
structure what are they
trees immutable trees right so many
times
doing something is going to write one
thing but every once in a while it's
going to write
more than one thing right it's going to
write other pieces of the data structure
as you have to write
intervening nodes and so there's not
necessarily a trivial mapping
between a failure at the right level and
then what happens up here
so the question then is
well there's a couple of questions i
wanted to try to write 100 log blocks
i succeeded in writing 100 log blocks
even with a failure rate of 1 in 20
because there's a built-in retry
strategy and there were nine retries
the question is how do i know there were
nine retries
what evidence would i have for that this
is a place where i think people
often go in the wrong direction right
because
five years ago what i would have reached
for here is mocking and stubbing
right i would have i would have created
this new special world
that had nothing to do with my
production environment and tried to
sort of you know play with that and
figure out if this works
well what i want to do here is look at
side effects that would happen in the
real environment
and try to make decisions based on those
things what would be a visible side
effect
of a retry
well let me let me let me back up if
retry has no side effects then i don't
ever need to bother testing it
right it must have some side effect but
you can always think this now sometimes
it's going to be computationally
inconvenient
or impossible to do this i'm not saying
you can get away with never mocking and
stubbing
but you can get away with it a lot more
often than you would think what evidence
am i going to have that there's going to
be a retry
what's that time time is one piece of
evidence what else
there may or may not be network activity
but that's a good one
this is below that so we won't see it up
at that level that's a good guess
um with apologies to bradford one of the
other things we're going to have is logs
right um and by the way when we we have
the official mark granigan seal of
approval
logs our maps going but but we do write
logs so we can you know look at things
that happen so logs there are also
metrics so aws has this great
cloud watch metrics so you could have a
cloud watch metric that said ouch
uh i tried to write to dynamo and didn't
go well and in fact dynamo has its own
metrics so you probably have already
triggered a metric
down at the dynamo level in addition to
uh the metric at your level
so there are all kinds of ways that we
could get this number of retries
without mocking or stubbing anything and
you can take your choice in this case i
actually got it from the log
uh but there are you know there are
other ways to do it
one of the things that i hope comes out
of all these examples that i've just
shown
is that tests are programs
that i mean that sounds kind of trite
that's because i'm the master of trite
but tests are programs and in particular
uh every test can be a different kind of
program right the unifying
testing framework that we use testing
daytonic
is a program launcher and you can fail
the build if somebody throws an
exception
right because the individual programs
are all very different
in particular a lot of the programs go
through this little guy
so i suspect like many people that when
i'm testing something initially i test
it
at the rebel or i write a little script
if i write a little script
and it has a little bit of validation or
some exception that it would though if
something's wrong
i can throw it in a directory in
daytonic and it will run it in this
incredibly brilliant custom repl right
that just sits there and runs it as if i
had typed it in
it just prints out then the user did
this and then he saw this and
so it's like a way to go back and
reproduce an interactive session that
you did at the rebel and this is a very
poor man's thing to do
right compared to some other things one
might do
but a key element to having tests is
being able to have
a gradation from things that are really
easy to do
up to things that are a lot more
powerful and so it's very easy to just
take a
rebel interaction and say i'm going to
add that to the test suite
now on the other end this is on the
super lightweight uh poor mansion
on the other end we have the sim and
the sim is the big monster and so the
idea behind the stem
is that there is a database
called the sim database and the sim
database has a bunch of actors
so people who are people or processes
who are interacting with the system
and it has a bunch of actions that
they're going to take described as data
and time stamped and then you take all
of that
and you run it with a runner the runner
fires up a bunch of elastic beanstalk
instances
and then looks at the sim data and says
well you know at time t
actor number seven tries to do this
query and at time t
plus five actor number eight issues this
transaction and so forth
and so what this gives you is a
simulated real use of this of the system
and you can generate uh you know
pick your own probabilistic
distributions of different kinds of
activities
uh create different kinds of loads and
run them
uh through the runner and then
later you can run validation so a
separate validator program
can look at the result of running the
sim and what it's going to have access
to
is the sim data which is in a database
the same data is in this really flexible
database where everything's time stamped
and there's a logic language for
querying it
so it's really easy to get to or you
could look at the thing we're testing
the orders data so the system actually
pretends to be a little catalog store
the orders data is also in one of these
nice really flexible schema
databases and the validations in this
world
so there are a lot of well there are a
lot of things about this device first
off simulation is not a precious curated
path
right it allows you to have real
concurrency and real separate things
going on uh it uses real input and
output it has a model for time
it separates your testing activities and
time and space when do i have to write
the validation for the sim i
ran last week what information do i have
about it
all right we throw all the logs into s3
we have the
cloudwatch metrics we have the database
of inputs the database of outputs
the input and output databases have time
stamps i can go back
six years from now and write a
validation and say were we correct
you know on march 15th and validations
can be logic programs
right the validators themselves can be
logic programs now the downside of all
this is
this one will take longer to set up than
all those cheapy things i showed you
before
so when you run out to do this you
should allow yourself at least 30 or 45
minutes
i want to wrap up by quickly um
reminding i went through daytonic's code
base and preparing this talk
and just thought about you know where
did closure really jump out and make a
difference
and in a lot of ways this is the usual
suspects
right immutable data functions uh
closures reference types protocols
uh this audience knows how these things
make your life a lot easier the one
thing that i want to call out is that
as i was thinking through it data really
was on top
even more than functions just the
rigorous insistence on staying in
data where possible and you saw that
throughout this talk
queries or data transactions or data
right you saw the symptom of it in that
the size of the apis
are asymptotically approaching zero
there are no apis because everything is
just data
and as an industry we've been really
terrible about that and we're starting
to get better
i also think that daytonic clearly shows
a lot of closure philosophy
there's probably some continuity in the
design effort i would argue
which causes that and you know we've
talked about simplicity power and focus
before
the thing i want to call out above all
of that though is
um architecture or if you want to say it
upfront design right thinking through
things
you can't build something substantial
by taking an incremental walk from where
you are right to get somewhere
substantial eventually you have to leap
from some local minimum to some other
local minimum
and to get somewhere really substantial
you've got to get a bunch of different
things in play
and look at their costs and their
benefits related to each other
rich has already said these things
better than i say them right you can
people have watched the
uh the hammock talk and things like that
but it's super important
it's important to how closure and closer
script were designed uh and it's
important to how
the atomic was designed as well
so if 2011
was the year of functions i am hoping
that 2012
will be the year of data i'd like to
ask everyone to give alex miller a big
[Applause]
hand
and now because it's just ridiculous
right i mean they have this social more
that now you've done
you've done a bunch of applause and now
i'm done so you have to plot again
don't right we just we can just be done
this has been really terrific
i hope we will be back here or in
portland or wherever
uh in a year's time uh thanks to all the
sponsors to all the great speakers all
the great conversations
and uh we'll all see each other at the
next big closure event thank you